alright let me summarize this this is a
movie about robbery and corrupt cops and
crime starring Kate Winslet Norman
Reedus Aaron Paul Casey Affleck Chiwetel
Ejiofor Anthony Mackie Woody Harrelson
clifton collins jr. i mean i don't know
about you but that's a recipe that
sounds like some pretty good tasting
cake what does it actually taste like
boredom
triple nine so triple nine stars
everybody I just listed off to you
including gal gadot in the movie love to
talk about her more I thought there was
gonna be the movie that made me go oh my
god she's a really good actress but she
didn't do much that she was bad in the
role she did she was just there to be
hot she did that well so ultimately in
this movie their group of criminals and
they robbed a bank at the beginning and
then they have to do another heist later
on in the movie in order to pull that
off they have to create a distraction of
sorts and then all just kind of falls
apart and goes awry that's the
interesting summary of the movie not
gonna lie to you guys this movie had
some [ __ ] pacing that speaks nothing for
the performances the performances in the
movie were fine Woody Harrelson's kind
of another animal all together and we'll
get into him later but all in all I
thought Casey Affleck was really good in
the movie chiwetel ejiofor II thought he
was great Anthony Mackie the people
bring it how you would think they would
bring in fact is they're in a crime
movie that's a bit of a snooze and that
whole mob element is interesting and
I've seen it in movies like this a
hundred times but the mob elements the
thing that puts it over the edge I mean
if it was just corrupt cops were out
there doing robberies and the cops are
looking for the robbers and half of them
are actually cops I'd be interesting
enough I don't know why you need a mob
element the whole mob element made it
feel like that was supposed to be in
another movie and somehow the writer was
like you know I'm just going to stitch
it up in a Frank and stitch it into this
movie now it's kind of three
Frankenstein movies into one movie for
three-quarters of this movie I was just
like come on something happened then
when it all actually comes to a head and
it starts going down it was really
interesting I was like oh hey hey let's
perk up we're here now I'll give the
movie that a whole big heist and this
and that and the way they interacted and
the way they fed into each other that
was pretty cool in the movie wraps up
you're like well okay I'd like to say it
was worth the wait but oh wow it's still
going the movie is not ending oh no ring
on the Return of the King ending here
because we have some road to travel yet
yep it just keeps trucking along it's
like the Energizer Bunny man it's almost
dududu - nope not ending then I swear to
God the last shot was happening and it
started to fade and everybody got it in
their heads they were like I don't know
if this is the final fade but I am
getting up and I'm leaving theater
before the fade was done when it was
fading current text fading to black
people started getting up they were like
I don't care did fade to black credits
came on and I was like oh thank god even
Woody Harrelson in this movie I don't
know what it is Woody Harrelson is such
a good actor but I've seen them do this
to him in a few different movies where
it's like he has to be so extreme in his
role that he's ultimately a cartoon
version of the role he's supposed to be
doing I don't know if that's a director
thing I don't know if that's Woody
Harrelson thing but it needs to stop
don't go Johnny Depp don't go full deaf
on us woody come on guys in the end
triple nine had an interesting premise
and a great solid cast but the great
cast and the great premise is the
difference between potential and reality
in reality this movie was kind of a mess
and in the end I'm not gonna remember
triple 9 and t-minus one day ya already
forgot all right guys so triple 9 have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite corrupt cop
movie of all time whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more